hey guys I'm a be sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen if you're just tuning in
to the channel I want to give you a
little taste of what you can expect from
me so that you can subscribe to the
channel ASAP so here we go a few facts
about me first off I tend to swear a lot
I'm gonna pie this her loose my sheet
these ladies must funky with their lives
it is I tend to make some funny faces
and noises when I screw up what I want
to say I like to pretend I'm a Star Wars
no no no all day aerodeck doing strange
awkward dances pumps me up
not unusual greatest dance
well she's dance killed she's dance whoa
no sweet potato toast cool rolling I
have an alter ego named Debbie and she
wears blue leotards that are far too
small for her and is obsessed with the
latest diets let's be honest we all know
a Debbie I'm doing a cleanse this week -
totally detox from the holidays thousand
thirty 1040 - it's got meat all the kale
by the end of a long shoot day I am
definitely at craving a drink so I tend
to talk about foods a lot guys let's
talk about booze and you don't want them
getting passed out drunk on boxed wine
oh I love day drinking yes I have a
favorite phrase that you're probably
gonna hear me say a lot so good so good
it's so good so good so good this is so
good I love hanging with fun foodie
people in the kitchen and doing awesome
YouTube collaborations today we are
celebrating Valentine's date with my
friend Julie from feeling peckish
mathis Ely from Fidel Castro's De Vita
from the healthy maven Nia Vardalos is
here Nikki from health nut nutrition I'm
totally obsessed with high protein
recipes from stuffing to oatmeal to
snacks to pancakes if I can boost the
protein I will
[Music]
so guys I'm just getting warmed up
there's so much more fun to be had if
you enjoyed these hilarious little
snippets be sure to subscribe to the
channel leave me a comment below with
some ideas for what you guys want to see
in an upcoming video like this video and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
subscribe
you